we'll take advantage of what the
framework offers in order to build our
settings activity since we're supporting
gingerbread devices will use a
preference activity class if you're
targeting honeycomb or later you'll want
to use a preference fragment class
create a new settings activity class
from the gist provided below update the
Android manifest to declare this new
activity you can see the way detail
activity is declared as an example if
you see that api's are deprecated that's
okay that's a side effect of using
preference activity in order to target
gingerbread devices when you create your
app for your final project you can use
the wizard and Android studio to create
a new settings activity the code the
wizard provides will make your app
backward compatible by using a
combination of preference activity and
preference fragment our gist is meant to
be a simplified version of that for
learning purposes so later you'd be able
to understand better what the wizard is
doing you took these items off when
you're done